hey alicia my horoscope says we're
destined to dance together
my horoscope says beware of dorks
well i'll protect you from them now
for our final couple with a new dance
they've invented called
the sprain screech powers and lisa
turtle
bring them on
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
um
[Music]
[Applause]
3.
[Applause]
hey there is no doubt about it we have a
winner it is screech and lisa
well that's a good night from us here at
dance party everybody till next time
this is casey case i'm saying keep your
feet in the ground
and keep reaching for the stars come on
everybody
let's do the the spring
[Music]
lisa i think you better total up
everything you bought right now
really i have a calculator on my watch
you can use it if you hold my wrist
screech heel
where are the receipts here
62 for the top 126 for the jacket and
shorts and 198 for the boots purse
and man-eater perfume come on what's the
total
386. 386.
you think i went overboard like the crew
of the titanic
this is serious lisa when your father
finds out you are gonna get in trouble
oh come on i'm daddy's little girl
if you want to live to be daddy's big
girl take the stuff back
lisa why can't you tell your father
because i don't know how he'll react
come in hi sweetheart
hi daddy what do you want to talk to me
about
daddy i don't know what to do i've made
a big mistake
oh i'm sure it's not that bad princess
tell your father
he knows best
[Music]
okay daddy i've run up a 400
bill on your credit card
[Music]
i'm sorry who's the worst
daughter of all lisa lisa
you are a father's worst
[Music]
nightmare
what's happened to me
i'm not daddy's little girl anymore
no the kelly's big zac it's time to
snatch me up before i'm taken
can you go to the prom with me yeah i'll
go
you will i'll go with you when worms
have
you're ears more popcorn
i guess so
i got the wine container so both our
hands can fit in at once
um screech would you go get me some
chocolate mop balls
i knew you'd want them
you know popcorn really makes me thirsty
do you think he's going
cola a rock
the police
hey no arm no soda
when did the zombies fall in love she'll
see
is that the zombie no that's his
mother-in-law his mommy
where's matt dylan he's not in this
movie just watch
there's a zombie what
quiet
[Laughter]
he's cute for dead guy there's some
females on me
can't you see she's wearing high heels
you're in a fashion
are you sure matt dillon's not in this
movie yes i learned thick as the zombie
everybody knows that
what a great movie screech
are you i missed most of the movie
because i'm motor mouth down there
next time go to the movies with matt
dylan this has been the worst date of my
life
forget the prom
[Applause]
wait wait a minute you're not supposed
to dump me i'm supposed to dump you
would you ever go study with a guy named
moose why not you could always hang your
coat on his antlers
thank you for coming hey lisa who are
you going to the prom with
oh it's too early to tell i've given
definite maybes to six guys
well nobody's asked me to go yet oh
kelly you're one of the hottest girls in
school
a lot of guys are gonna ask you hey lisa
i wanted to talk to you about the prom
uh screech i can't go with you i got
married during third period
poor guy
how are you doing screech well since you
asked i'm miserable
there's no girl in school who will go to
the prom with me
listen you're smart you're sweet
you're a little strange but that's what
makes you interesting
you keep asking and i'm sure you'll find
some girl who'll be thrilled to go with
you
thanks lisa you're wrong but i feel
better just knowing you care
but don't worry i'll i'll keep my
promise i won't ask you
scritch what if
what if i ask you that's a good one but
i'm too depressed to laugh
i'm serious will you go to the prom with
me
will i will i of course i will
waitress do your best milkshakes right
down here this is the next day
chris
did i hear what i thought i heard well
you know i can pick between all the
favorites
so i look for the underdog
you